hello everyone welcome to another coffee
break here on my channel firm learning
today i want to talk about the terrible
events in ukraine and how this affects
consulting firms and especially the
russian business of the consulting firms
around the world after russia invading
the ukraine you see many organizations
around the world to speak up and take
actions by for instance stopping
business in russia though is this the
case for the consulting firms as well
and what are maybe differences among the
different firms and how they react to
the russian business and of course what
does this imply for the employees
working in these russian organizations
so this is what i want to talk about
today in this video i will donate all
the youtube ad revenue that i receive
from this video to the unhcr which is
the un agency mandated to aid and
protect refugees around the world
they're currently also active in ukraine
so if you watch the video we'll directly
contribute to that if you watch the ads
and watch until the very end thank you
very much for your support on this so in
order to put together this video i did
some desk research read lots of press
statements also statements on linkedin
the many consulting firms and the
leaders of these firms published and i
reached out to you on instagram asking
for your first hand impressions first
and insider knowledge on what is going
on in all these consulting firms and
what they're doing with their russian
organization so thanks so much for all
the messages that i did receive but do
want to say is a disclaimer that first
the situation is dynamically evolving so
potentially the information i'm sharing
right now is not accurate anymore in a
couple of days or a couple of weeks and
second because lots of the information
i'm sharing in this video is from you
from the community i've no direct way of
verifying it though if any of you proves
me wrong that anything i say as of today
is not accurate i will include a pinned
post in the comment section with any
clarifications or any amendments or
corrections of what i'm saying so let's
get started and first of all i think
it's fair to say that the whole
situation did leave a mark on the
consulting industry lots of firms did
take action the moment will go firm by
firm for many of the major firms what
exactly they did they even was a
statement from alexander kravchenko
which was the managing director of
mckinsey in ukraine who released a post
on linkedin saying that the russian
actions were a military crime so from my
experience such a candid political
statement is rather rare from the
leadership of any big consulting firm as
far as i know that person also uttered
that as a private person not necessarily
as an official spokesperson for the firm
but still this reaction is remarkable
and surely nothing like everyday
business what's going on right now let's
look into individual reforms and let's
start with the mbb strategy consulting
firms for mckinsey bcg and bain shortly
after the news of the invasion mckinsey
released a statement saying that they
will not conduct any work for the
russian government and then a couple of
days later they extended that to not
accepting any new work for any russian
client whatsoever and rather similar
statements were released by the
leadership of boston consulting group
and of bain so what exactly does this
mean for the staff of these
organizations working in russia once
again i want to reiterate that all of
this information was collected from the
community i wasn't able to verify any of
it feel free to leave a comment if you
know more and apparently for mckinsey
the situation is that many colleagues
got transferred to the kazakhstan office
and from there they will conduct lion
work for especially middle eastern
clients but then also other
international projects and i know from
at least one instance where an offer
that a candidate received during the
interview process was postponed in
boston consulting group they seem to be
in the middle of the process of
reallocating consultants to other
offices so the process seems to be more
top down not necessarily only focus on
one office but more depending on the
individual situation of the consultants
and here i've been told that especially
for some juniors this process poses some
issues so far it doesn't seem to be
clear what will happen to the colleagues
who are in the end not able to make this
switch to make this transition to
another office bain seems to have
transferred a good part of their
consultants to the dubai office and then
helping them to get staffed on
international projects also projects in
the middle east as with the other firms
it seems to be an ongoing process but i
have been told by sources from all of
these firms that so far there was no
layoff directly related to the situation
in ukraine next is oliver wyman and
while the oliver wyman leadership stated
that they don't want to conduct any more
client work in russia there was a press
release from marsh mclennan which is the
company that owns oliver wyman that said
we intend to transfer ownership of our
russian businesses to local management
will operate independently in the
russian market so what this means is and
i got this confirmed from some local
sources that apparently they're trying
to do is that they're asking the
partners the local partners in russia to
buy out the russian organization of
oliver wyman and then potentially
continue operating it under a different
name now in this video i don't want to
judge these actions i trust this might
be good news to the russian employees as
maybe likely they will not lose the job
or might not need to move to other
countries other regions other offices i
also understand though that so far
there's no definite agreement on this
matter similar to the others kearney
also released a statement that they want
to stop any work for russian clients but
do want to keep the offices still open
so far was frankly not able to collect
any insider information from any russian
employee at kearney right now so if you
have anything to share on that please
leave a comment in the comment section
next is olamberger they behaving very
much in line with the other companies so
they're stopping any client activities
in russia to my knowledge leaving the
offices open for now they are relocating
colleagues mainly to the middle east and
also some other international offices in
helping them to get staff to
international projects from there
accenture arguably took the most drastic
measures from the companies on this list
they completely discontinued all
operations in russia and laid off all of
their apparently 2
300 people working in that country
overall the whole organization was laid
off and the severance offer that these
people receive this at least was i was
told is that they got three monthly
salaries as a severance payment let's
next talk about the big four so this is
pwc kpmg e y and deloitte what's first
important to understand is that we talk
about the big four firms that due to
legal regulations also due to their
audit business they are structured in
local legally independent subsidiaries
so there is a legal entity for the
russian business for each of these four
companies and what all of these four
firms announced is that they want to
stop the affiliation of the russian
entity from the global network of any of
these four firms so what this means is
that the entity that was for instance
called pwc russia in the future cannot
call itself pwc anymore but that entity
still exists and can still continue its
operation and i trust this is what is
happening for all the four big four
companies so in all fairness given that
these are legally independent entities
it probably was more or less difficult
maybe even impossible than for the
mother organization to completely stop
the operations in this country of course
i'm not a legal expert on these issues
the result surely is that these entities
will continue its operations likely
under a new name in the future and i
received some details from an internal
memo of one of these russian
organizations from one of these firms
and in this memo russian leadership
stated that they actually see the
situation from now on positively because
now there will be less competition from
international firms and on top they will
also get access to lots of talent from
other consulting firms staff that was
laid off or did not want to relocate to
any other location those of course are
people who will likely maybe want to
work for any of these firms going
forward so interesting situation let me
know what you think about this in the
comments hope this served as an
informative overview of the situation of
consulting firms in russia if you took
any value out of this video is always
destroy the like button for the youtube
algorithm and also subscribe to stay up
to date on my content big big thanks to
all the members of this channel
supporting my work once again i will
donate all ad revenue from this video to
the un refugee agency my name is
heinrich i release weekly videos every
saturday thank you all for watching
until next week and goodbye